[Musique]
Joseph Tiglitz, bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement
?
Je à l'université Colombia,
je suis économiste
était économiste en chef de la mondiale
et j'étais le conseiller économique du
président Clinton.
Première fois en France,
ce n'est pas la première fois que je
viens en France, loin de là.
J'ai travaillé avec un bon nombre de
présidents français.
Vous avez été pris Nobel d'économie. Euh
vous avez écrit un livre qui parle de
peuple de pouvoir et de profit.
Nous on voudrait avoir votre avis sur ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle avec les
gilets jaunes. Ce mouvement,
les gilets jaunes posent un certain
nombre de problèmes assez complexes. en
réalité le mouvement des gilets jaunes
et le résultat est une augmentation de
la taxe carbone
taxe sur les carburants plus
précisément.
Pourtant l'objectif était louable
l'objectif de cette augmentation de la
taxe visait à protéger la planète et
pour réduire la consommation de
carburant. Néanmoins, cela a générement
profond au sein de la population
française.
Ce mécontentement,
il est à de très nombreux facteurs.
Du reste, c'est assez similaire au
mécontentement auquel on assiste aux
États-Unis.
En effet, il y a
certaines parties de la population qui
n'ont pas bénéficié de la croissance de
l'économie.
Il y a des groupes de la population qui
pensent queon n'a pas écouté leurs
préoccupations, qu' du pour s'exprimer
ou alors ils se sont sentis rejetés.
Aux États-Unis, il y a des régions où le
revenu a stagné voire apaissé et
pourtant le revenu moyen aux États-Unis
n'a fait qu'augmenter.
Ainsi,
il y a des tensions.
Par ailleurs, il y a des difficultés
liées aux politiques qui sont menées.
L'augmentation des impôts pour les gens
qui sont en difficulté juste après avoir
baissé les impôts des riches,
et bien inévitablement, ça va donner
l'impression que l'on creuse les
inégalités. C'est le cas d'ailleurs et
c'est profondément injuste
[Musique]
lorsque les habitants des zones rurales
qui doivent
conduire
se déplacer en voiture lorsqu'on les
oblige à payer plus pour le carburant
après avoir
éliminé les transports en commun que ça
soit les autobus ou le rail et ben il
semblerait qu'on mène une bataille
contre ces gens-là, qu'on leur en veut
d'une façon ou une autre, ce n'est pas
le cas. Mais à tout le mois, on peut
dire qu'on n pas tenu compte de leur
préoccupation et de leur mode de vie.
Même si en moyenne, je dis bien en
moyenne, la taxe carbone
soit progressive, à savoir les riches
dépensent plus
en carburant.
voitures sont plus grosses et ainsi de
suite. En moyenne,
la taxe est surtout payée par
les riches que par les pauvres. Il y a
quand même de très nombreux pauvres
qui
sont encore plus mal de par
l'augmentation de la taxe. Alors que
quand on lance un programme économique,
il faut pas s'intéresser à la moyenne,
il faut s'intéresser sur les sur les
gilets jaunes ou sur la la
partie de la population qui est exposée
à ce type de taxe. J'aimerais qu'on
parle de système financier. J'aimerais
qu'on parle de d'injection de liquidité.
J'aimerais surtout qu'on parle de la
politique de la Fed et ce revirement de
la politique de la Fed avec les
dernières injections de liquidité.
Toute politique doit être analysé dans
son contexte économique
et au fil des années,
on a assisté au fait que certains
groupes de la population se portent bien
alors que d'autres pas du du tout
certaines politiques économiques telles
que la baisse des taux d'intérêt négatif
rate
ou alors les taux d'intérêt négatif oui
peuvent être bénéfiques pour certaines
personnes mais pas pour d'autres par
exemple
le problème est le même aux États-Unis
lorsque la Fed a baissé les taux
d'intérêt
cela signifiait que les personnes à
qui
dépendait des obligations d'État et bien
ont vu leur revenu disparaître.
Mais
en même temps, étant donné la faiblesse
des taux d'intérêt, bien la bourse n'a
fait qu'augmenter.
Par conséquent, les personnes très
aisées qui avaient un gros portefeuille
d'action s'en sont très bien sortis.
Donc cela augmenté la croissance
économique mais un tout petit peu. Donc
ça a eu quand même un effet bénéfique
sur la croissance économique. Ça a évité
une
Mais c'est très dangereux d'injecter
autant de dollars pour avoir un retour
sur investissement si bas.
On est passé de 800 milliards à 4
milliers de milliards.
Il y a eu un petit peu de croissance
économique et encore une fois on a évité
une baisse de l'économie. Mais ça a été
fait selon une méthode qui a enrichi les
riches
et les retraités
les retraités modestes. J'entends les
gens qui avaient investi dans des
obligations d'état et bien ces gens-là
ont vu leur revenu baisser. C'est ça que
je veux dire, c'est que lorsquon mène
une politique économique quelle qu'elle
soit, il faut quand même se soucier
des gens qui vont perdre, des gens qui
vont gagner.
Et il faut
concevoir des moyens de protéger ceux
qui vont perdre, particulièrement s'il
s'agit des gens euh
défavorisés et des gens de la classe
moyenne, la classe moyenne.
Malheureusement, nos responsables
politiques n'agissent pas comme ça.
Est-ce que je vais ma question va être
des coupé en en deux parties. Est-ce que
les dernières injections de liquidité de
la Fed sont dues au collatéral
qui ne sont plus de bonne qualité ?
C'està-dire que les banques sont
obligées d'utiliser des collatérales
pour assurer leur leur leurs emprunts ou
leurs échanges interbancaires. Est-ce
que les collatéraux sont devenus de
tellement mauvaise qualité que c'est la
Fed qui a été obligé de se mettre entre
les deux pour rétablir de la confiance ?
Et la deuxième partie de ma question
concerne le fait les marchés financiers
sont devenus tellement rapides,
accélèrent tellement, est-ce que ces
mesures de économiques ne sont pas là
pour masquer le fait qu'on ne peut pas
ralentir les marchés financiers ?
Moi, je pense que l'on peut gérer les
marchés financiers. On peut le faire
bien mieux que ce n'a été le cas jusqu'à
présent. L'un
des problèmes aux États-Unis, par
exemple,
c'est le trading haute fréquence.
C'est pas des gens qui échangent des
titres avec d'autres gens. Non, c'est
des ordinateurs qui se parlent entre eux
et ceux à très grande vite très grande
vitesse. Si rapidement d'ailleurs que si
vous êtes
à 1 km de la bourse et ben vous êtes
foutu. Il faut être dans le même
bâtiment. Il faut être localisé au même
endroit pour être concurrentiel. Voilà
une activité économique qui n'apporte
aucune valeur à la société.
C'est en fait une fuite en avant. On
prend de l'information chez d'autres, on
exploite ces informations pour
s'enrichir et ce au détriment des gens
qui essayent de comprendre les rouages
de l'économie et qui essayent d'allouer
les ressources de manière plus efficace.
Si
il y avait une taxe sur les transactions
financières, autrement dit, à chaque
fois qu'il y a un échange financier, si
on devait payer une taxe, et bien cela
découragerait
ce genre de trading à haute fréquence.
S'il y avait des règlements, des règles
toutes simples
qui empêche les gens de d'afficher des
prix
et
de retirer le prix dès que un ordre est
passé, et bien ce genre d'activité
serait découragé. Donc il y a des
mesures fiscales qui peuvent être
envisagées. Il y a aussi des règles qui
peuvent être envisagées pour que ça soit
plus bénéfique aux sociétés. La société
n'est pas là pour servir le secteur
financier. C'est le monde à l'envers à
l'heure actuelle. Il y a dans mon livre
un aspect que j'évoque,
c'est le fait que nous avons créé une
économie de marché qui confère trop de
pouvoir au secteur financier,
trop de pouvoir au monopole et le
résultat c'est qu'il y a trop de
bénéfices pour les happy few et pas
assez de bien-être pour les citoyens.
Question euh la première partie de ma
question était sur les collatéraux.
Est-ce que vous sentez que le marchés
financiers sont obligés d'utiliser la
Fed pour rassurer ? C'est-à-dire que la
Fed s'interpose parce que les
collatéraux que les banques fournissent
ne sont plus d'ussi bonne qualité. Et
est-ce que vous pensez que le marché
financier est capable de ralentir ou
est-ce que le fait de faire ralentir le
marché financier ne deviendrait plus ou
ne deviendrait pas plus dangereux que de
continuer ces politiques monétaires très
très accommodantes ?
Une
façon générale,
je pense que nous pouvons nous assurer
que les marchés financiers
se concentrent sur leur finalité. Aucune
société ne peut fonctionner sans des
marchés financiers de qualité. Mais pour
autant, est-ce qu'on est-ce que les
marchés financiers sont de bons marchés
financiers ? Quelle est leur finalité ?
Et comment est-ce qu'on peut faire en
sorte qu'ils agissent pour leur finalité
? Par exemple, le les
épargnants
voient leur argent passer vers des
entreprises qui veulent se lancer dans
une activité, embaucher des gens et
ainsi de suite. Donc ça devrait être
comme ça. Aux États-Unis et dans de
nombreux autres pays, les marchés
financiers font le contraire. Ils
prennent l'argent des entreprises et ils
distribuent cet argent aux actionnaires
aisés et ils ne réinvestissent pas. En
décembre 2017, le président Trump a
accordé une réduction des impôts aux
milliardaires et aux entreprises très
riches. Qu'est-ce qu'elles en ont fait
les entreprises ? Et bien, elles ont
pris l'argent et elles ont racheté leurs
actions à hauteur de 1000 millions 1000
milliards de dollars en 2018.
Les marchés financiers ont joué un rôle
très important dans ce flux financier
qui est passé
euh des des entreprises
mais pas vers les investissements. Donc
la question est de savoir si on peut
faire en sorte que les marchés
financiers soient bénéfiques pour la
société. C'est absolument nécessaire. Si
ce n'était pas le cas, le système
capitaliste ne fonctionnera pas. Et
c'est pourquoi dans mon livre, j'essaie
de décrire la façon dont il faut s'y
prendre pour réformer le système
financier pour que ça fonctionne. Et une
partie de la réponse d'ailleurs est liée
au rôle des régulateurs, le rôle des
banques centrales, la Fed aux
États-Unis, la BCE en Europe. La
question est la suivante : est-ce que
ces agents là peuvent faire en sorte que
le secteur financier réponde à la
finalité ? Vous avez entendu Jeanette
Kellen s'opposer aux audits de la Fed.
Qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait ? Est-ce
qu'il est important d'auditer les la ce
qu'il y a dans les coffres de la Fed, ce
qu'il y a dans le moteur de la Fed ? Un
audit de la Fed serait néfaste pour la
Fed ou un audit de la Fed rétablirait la
confiance dans la Fed ?
Je pense que toutes les institutions
financières publiques doivent être
transparentes.
Il y a un exemple que je connais de très
près,
c'est ce qui a lieu après que la Fed a
travaillé avec le trésor pour le
sauvetage de AIG. Là, on était à 180
milliards de dollars.
C'était un montant plus important que
celui qu'on avait donné au défavorisé.
Du jour au lendemain, on décide de
donner ce montant exorbitant à une seule
société. L'argent est arrivé chez AIG.
Mais où est-ce qu'il est passé cet
argent ? C'est ça la question.
La Fed a refusé de s'exprimer.
Donc il y a un député
Carole Maloni qui est député de New York
et j'ai moi j'ai dit en tant que
citoyen, moi je veux savoir
où l'argent du contribuable est passé.
J'ai donc écrit une lettre au congrès et
j'ai dit moi Joseph Stiglit citoyen,
j'ai le droit de savoir où est passé cet
argent.
Elle a fait valoir cette exigence en mon
nom. Et au bout d'un moment, la Fed nous
a répondu. Elle nous a expliqué où est
passé l'argent,
qui était le plus grand bénéficiaire. Et
bien l'argent est allé chez AG puis il
est ressorti.
Mais le plus gros bénéficiaire c'était
tenez-vous bien Goldman Socks.
Il est intéressant de noter que il y a
deux autres bénéficiaires qui étaient
des banques françaises.
Les banques françaises
ont pris l'argent et puis l'ont redonné
à tenez-vous bien Goldman Sax. Donc moi,
j'ai demandé au ministre des finances
françaises,
j'ai dit c'était très bien que les
États-Unis aide les banques françaises.
Très bien. Mais est-ce que c'était juste
? Et si c'était si important pour la
France, est-ce que vous vous auriez aidé
les banques françaises ? Et on m'a dit
mais oui bien sûr si c'était important
pour la France on aiderait les banques
françaises. Bien sûr qu'on accepter
l'aide des États-Unis si les États-Unis
veulent donner de l'argent aux banques
françaises. On n'est pas contre mais
ce n'était pas
dans l'intérêt du contribuable américain
ou du citoyen américain.
Fed
a rassemblé 180 milliards de dollars
pour aller vers une des plus grandes une
des banques les plus riches des
États-Unis et vers des banques
étrangères. C'est pas normal et ça
aurait dû être beaucoup plus
transparent. Nous citoyens, il aurait
fallu que l'on puisse connaître la
destination de cette argent du
contribuable.
Il aurait
fallu euh taper du point sur la table
pour savoir.
Moi, j'ai écrit, on l'a su, mais il y a
quelque chose qui allait pas.
Si elle refuse l'audit de la Fed, est-ce
que vous pensez qu'elle a des choses à
cacher ? Est-ce que la Fed a des choses
à cacher ? Parce que la Fed masque la
poussière, la saleté sous le tapis et ne
fait pas preuve de transparence parce
que le système financier est dans un tel
état que si elle se met à communiquer
d'une façon transparente, ça va changer
le chemin, la direction des marchés.
En fait, les choses sont un petit peu
plus compliquées que cela.
Il y a beaucoup d'échanges commerciaux
financiers disons entre la Fed et les
banques
dont on pourrait dire
que si les choses étaient transparentes
à tout moment, ça pourrait générer une
certaine panique sur les marchés. et la
Fed n'est pas là pour générer de la
panique. Il pourrait y avoir
des secrets commerciaux. Je sais pas
pourquoi, mais ça pourrait bien être le
cas.
Quoi qu'il en soit,
il y a des raisons compréhensibles
pour lesquelles toute l'information
n'est pas bonne à divulguer tout le
temps.
Mais on sait ce qui s'est passé en 2007.
Tout de même. En 2007,
il y avait une forte turbulence sur le
marché, un bouleversement même. Et le
Fed n'en a pas 10 mots, n'a pas pipé un
mot là-dessus. Si on avait été au
courant,
il y aurait une exigence de la part des
citoyens.
étant donné l'ampleur même de des
bouleversements qu'ont connu les marchés
financiers, on aurait pu s'attendre à ce
que la Fed ait une meilleure
compréhension des relations entre les
banques.
La Fed n'aurait pas dû être surprise de
la faillite de l'Embrers et de la
faillite du système financier. La Fed
n'a pas été suffisamment attentive. Elle
ne connaissait pas toutes ces relations
étant donné que la Fed savait qu'il y
avait des problèmes sur les marchés
financiers et la Fed n'a pas partagé
cette information avec les restes les
autres acteurs de l'économie. Donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que d'une
façon générale, il nous faut plus de
transparence.
Nous pouvons obtenir plus de
Mais peut-être faut-il
trouver un équilibre.
La Fed n'a pas très bien travaillé. Elle
ne s'est pas très bien défendue.
Surtout si on regarde ce qui s'est passé
dans la crise de 2008.
Mais là, il ne s'agit que d'une partie
du problème plus vaste du contrôle du
secteur financier. Le vrai problème à
mes yeux,
c'est le fait que le secteur financier
n'est pas bénéfique à la société. Il ne
sert pas la société comme il devrait le
faire. Le secteur financieux est passé
de 2,5 à 8 % du PIB. Et qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé avec la croissance
économique ? Ça a ralenti. Où est-ce
qu'on a vu cela ? Et ben, il y a eu plus
d'inégalité et plus de bénéfices entre
les mains des sociétés en situation de
monopole. C'est ça le problème. Le
pouvoir du marché a donné lieu à de très
fortes
inégalités et une économie dont la
performance est restée en Berne. Donc à
mes yeux, la chose la plus importante,
c'est comment se débarrasser de ce
pouvoir monopolistique ? Comment faire
en sorte que le secteur financier saura
ne plus exploiter les gens ? Et comment
peut-on
faire en sorte que les agents
économiques servent la société
financier peut-être qu'on sera amené à
parler du Glastigle Act et de choses
comme ça. J'aimerais qu'on aborde
maintenant une société qui s'appelle
Black Rock et le les ETF. Est-ce que
vous pensez que ces institutions sont
systémiques et est-ce que ces
institutions sont devenues tellement
dangereuses
qu'on détourne la tête et qu'on ne les
démentelle pas et qu'on ne leur impose
pas des régulations ?
Dans la réforme du système financier,
dans la loi de 2010,
nous avons
identifié
des grandes institutions systémiques,
lesquelles je me souviens pas, mais il y
avait non seulement les banques, mais
aussi des compagnies d'assurance.
Je ne sais pas si Black Rock avait été
identifié à l'époque, mais nous avions
fixé des critères
selon lesquels si ces institutions
passaient en faillite seruraient des
conséquences systémiques au niveau de
l'économie.
Donc l'idée de base est la bonne. On
peut toujours discuter pour savoir si
l'approche est suffisamment large. Mais
la préoccupation aujourd'hui, c'est que
le gouvernement Trump essaye
de rendre les choses de plus en plus
étroit pour qui a très peu d'acteurs
économiques et il essaie d'affaiblir la
réglementation.
Donc aujourd'hui, la situation n'est pas
la même aux États-Unis. Le débat est
différent.
À mon avis, la loi d'OD Franck de 2010
n'est pas allée suffisamment loin
pour empêcher
les banques de prendre trop de risques
ou de mener des activités
d'exploitation. Je vais vous donner un
autre exemple. Il y a une règle selon
laquelle il y avait une règle selon
laquelle les banques avaient
trop fait trop fait payer
et il y avait l'amendement dit
l'amendement d'urban pour réduire les
charges imposées par les banques. Le
pouvoir été délégué à la Fed, ce qui
montre beaucoup où se trouve l'intérêt
des banques. Fed a décidé de ne pas
traiter
euh euh cela. Les charges ont baissé
mais c'était néanmoins deux ou quatre
fois trop élevé mais rien n'a été fait
sur les cartes de crédit. Uniquement les
cartes de débit ont été affectées. Donc
c'était les dépenses sur les cartes de
débit dont il était question.
Et autrement dit, dans la plupart des
des opérations financières
avec des cartes de crédit, les dépenses,
les charges geliers sont encore
excessives. Donc la loi d'ODF Franck de
2010 n'a pas été suffisamment loin pour
éviter la prise de risque trop
importante.
Et aujourd'hui, nous sommes en 2019 et
le gouvernement Trump essaie d'affaiblir
la réglementation.
J'ai assisté à un dîner
où il y avait l'un des conseillers du
gouvernement Trump et cet homme-là
disait fièrement qu'ils allaient
déréglementer le secteur financier. Ça
c'était au début de l'administration
Trump. Et moi, j'ai dit mais
vous avez pas entendu parler de la crise
en 2008.
Le but de la réglementation,
c'est
justement les agissements du secteur
financier. Le secteur financier a nuit à
l'économie. Mais manifestement, je
parlais à un mur. C'est comme si
2008 c'était la préhistoire.
Euh est-ce que vous pensez que le fait
d'avoir ce modèle de de croissance sur
un système qui est en train de
s'apauvrir où les ressources naturelles
viennent à manquer, où les ressources
énergétiques viennent à manquer ? Vous
savez comme moi que on est toujours
sorti sorti d'une période récessive avec
une augmentation d'une consommation
énergétique, une augmentation de la
consommation énergétique mondiale.
À l'heure actuelle, les ressources
énergétiques
accessibles deviennent de plus en plus
compliquées. Est-ce que vous pensez que
si le système financier
nous emmène vers une récession, nous
pourrons ressortir de cette récession
par une consommation énergétique ? Si
elle n'est pas là, comment on fait ?
Avant toute chose, je dirais
nous sommes confrontés à une urgence
climatique.
GC
en 1995 a produit des rapports dont on
aurait dû tenir compte. On a commis une
erreur. On a vu à quel point c'était
sérieux le dérèglement climatique mais
on en a pas vu la rapidité.
On n'a pas pris la mesure
de
du dérèglement climatique. Alors, il y a
certes le réchauffement climatique, il y
a aussi
le monté des eaux et ont commencé à
recueillir des données
sur les événements météorologiques
extrêmes, les inondations,
les ouragans, les cyclones, tous ces
événements extrêmes qui provoquent des
dégâts énormes à la société et qui
provoquent des morts d'ailleurs.
Mais à ce stade là, en 95 rapport du GC,
ça remonte à 25 ans presque, on avait
pas suffisamment de données pour
faire le rapprochement entre la survenue
de ces événements extrêmes avec le
réchauffement climatique. Aujourd'hui,
nous comprenons que tout cela est lié et
nous prenons conscience de l'ampleur
du coût qui va nous incomber.
Nous sommes confrontés à une urgence
climatique
et nous devons traiter tous les
problèmes en même temps. On ne peut pas
dire "Oh bah, on va attendre encore 10
ans." Non,
le monde doit être neutre en carbone
d'ici 2050. C'est dans 30 ans seulement.
Autrement dit, nous devons envisager des
mesures très fortes. D'une certaine
façon, on peut quand même trouver du bon
là-dedans parce que
ajuster l'économie
à une nouvelle situation où on lutte
contre le changement climatique,
l'investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables, les nouvelles sources
énergies,
l'éolien, le solaire.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons la technologie à
notre disposition.
Nous avons la technologie
capable de produire une énergie
renouvelable.
Le cycle de vie de l'énergie utilise
encore des ressources certes, mais nous
sommes clairement en train de réduire
l'empreinte carbone. Nous avons la
technologie pour le faire.
Bon, évidemment, on est on n pas atteint
la perfection, mais on peut faire des
progrès spectaculaires et si on
investissait plus dans la recherche, ce
serait encore mieux.
Donc à mes yeux et encore une fois, nous
sommes confrontés à une urgence
climatique et les investissements
nécessaires créeraient des emplois.
Il y a des ressources sous-exploitées en
Europe, aux États-Unis.
Donc l'idée c'est qu'en s'attaquant
au problèmes climatiques
et bien l'économie pourra croître plus
rapidement et on pourra créer des
emplois parc de croissance économique.
Moi, je vais vous poser une question
très simple. Est-ce que les marchés
financiers sont designés pour encaisser
un monde qui rentre en décroissance ?
Les marchés financiers pourraient
fonctionner,
mais ça nous ramène à la question
précédente.
Mais il faut s'assurer donc que les
marchés financiers soient utiles à la
société.
Donc on peut dire pas de prêt pour les
central à charbon
nuisible à la société, ça détruit
l'environnement, on est d'accord.
Autrement dit, on peut prendre des
mesures comme ça. On peut mettre fin aux
pratiques les pires simplement par de
simples règles. Aux États-Unis,
certains États dans l'État de New York
ont créé une nouvelle banque,
une banque verte.
Le but, c'est la promotion
[Musique]
de l'économie verte.
C'est une banque publique.
Elle a été créée par l'État
et ça a été créé notamment parce que le
secteur le secteur privé ne faisait pas
son boulot. Donc, il nous faudra
peut-être créer de nouvelles
institutions à l'échelle internationale.
On met plus l'accent
sur la promotion des énergies
renouvelables, les énergies vertes. Les
banques de développement multilatéral
font cela. Elles travaillent sur la
promotion de la transition verte. Et ce
que je voudrais souligner ici, c'est
qu'il ne s'agit pas simplement
d'énergie, il s'agit d'un changement
total de la structure de notre économie.
Plus de transport public,
les logements, les bâtiments
qui ne seraient plus des passoirs
thermiques.
Il faut concevoir les villes de telle
sorte que l'on ait plus à se déplacer
autant. C'est un projet très ambitieux.
qu'il nous faut adopter. Mais nous
n'avons pas de choix. C'est nécessaire,
c'est indispensable et nous allons le
faire d'une façon ou d'une autre. Est-ce
qu'on va le faire trop tard
en remettant tout au lendemain ? En une
seule année, les États-Unis ont perdu
près de 2 % de PIB en raison des
événements climatiques extrêmes. Et là,
c'est un exemple
du fait que le secteur financier ne sert
pas la société. Et dans mon livre,
j'essaie d'expliquer qu'il nous faut
réformer le capitalisme pour que le
capitalisme soit utile à la société. Une
partie de cette réforme consiste à nous
assurer que l'on peut vivre selon les
limites de la planète.
Toujours toujours la croissance
économique. Je vous parler de
décroissance.
Il y a une interview dans le Guardian
très récente d'un d'un scientifique qui
s'appelle Vaclav.
Il dit "La croissance doit cesser. Nos
amis économistes ne semblent pas s'en
rendre compte.
Ce que veut dire par là, c'est le genre
de croissance que l'on connaît depuis
100 ans. Donc la croissance qui repose
sur les énergies fossiles,
une utilisation intensive de matériaux
de matière première croissance qui
repose sur l'exploitation des
ressources. Mais il y a d'autres formes
de croissance envisageable. Par exemple,
les services de santé, là ça exploite
très peu de ressources.
Les
dans les pays les riches, il y a des
services de santé.
Mais on peut pas dire aux pauvres,
restez où vous êtes.
Nous, on va profiter de la qualité de la
vie avec un bon système de santé, mais
vous vous aurez un mauvais système de
santé. Le fait de leur donner une un bon
système de santé, c'est de la richesse.
Mais c'est pas de la richesse
matérielle, c'est pas de la croissance
sale
comme celle qu'on a eu dans le passé.
Donc il va falloir muter. Je vais vous
donner un autre exemple. Nous savons
que
les
l'empreinte de carbone dépend du mode de
conservation. L'empreinte carbone de la
viande est pire que
régime végan. Et les jeunes sont en
train de changer leur façon de
s'alimenter en fonction de la
compréhension
du fait que nous devons vivre selon les
ressources limitées de la planète.
Est-ce que ça se produit suffisamment
vite ? Question.
Bouch a dit le train de vie des
Américains n'est pas négociable. Est-ce
que vous pensez que la société
américaine est prête à avoir une
attitude de consommation énergétique
plus mature ? Où est-ce que vous pensez
que les pouvoirs américains vont
continuer la guerre économique pour
maintenir le train de vie des Américains
? Est-ce que la société américaine n'est
pas trop immature pour basculer dans ce
changement de paradigme ?
Attendez, je je vais m'expliquer.
Je voudraism
parler des deux optimisme et pragmatisme
si vous voulez.
Si l'on regarde les jeunes,
regardez un petit peu les études
de
ils veulent des priorités progressistes.
la moitié, les de tiers même veulent des
priorités progressistes et tous les
jeunes se rendent compte que le chgement
climatique doit faire l'objet d'une
urgence
et de plus en plus de gens prennent
conscience de cet impératif.
Cette partie de la population qui
change, qui s'approprie ces sujets
climatiques n'est pas au pouvoir et se
voit opposé une force policière ou une
génération qui a le capital encore en
poche, le pouvoir, le réseau. Est-ce que
vous êtes en train de dire à la jeune
génération d'aller se battre pour
prendre ce qui leur appartient et
déboulonner l'ancienne génération ?
cette génération qui a gâché leur
enfance pour reprendre les les mots de
Gratonberg.
Comment la jeune génération peut
s'approprier ça avec un pouvoir policier
à un état qui surveille avec un état qui
est tétanisé par ce changement de
paradigme ?
C'est là que je vous dis que je suis
optimiste. Il y a une élection
présidentielle aux États-Unis en 2020.
Et les démocrates vont gagner
et ils vont gagner en partie
en raison du militantisme des jeunes.
Souvenez-nous que les
enfants ont des parents et des
grands-parents. Autrement dit, les
parents et les grands-parents
connaissent désormais les risques
auxquels sont confrontés les enfants en
raison du dérèglement climatique.
Il y a certes
un phénomène générationnel à l'œuvre et
la voix des jeunes est de plus en plus
fortement exprimée. C'est très
intéressant.
Nous avons fait venir
à chez à Colombia
et
les jeunes américains sont pas très
impliqués dans la vie politique et bien
c'est en train de changer
parce que les jeunes se rendent compte
que c'est leur avenir qui est en jeu.
et moi,
je crois qu'il va y avoir des campagnes
à l'échelle nationale aux États-Unis.
Les jeunes se rendent bien compte des
enjeux.
Donc
le parti Républicain, lui veut qui a de
moins en moins d'électeurs.
Il y aura des manipulations et il y aura
des choses assez désagréables pendant la
campagne présidentielle. Mais au bout du
compte, les démocrates vont être au
pouvoir à la Maison Blanche. Ils sont
déjà au la chambre des députés depuis
2018. On se rend compte
de la catastrophe
qui que connaîtront les États-Unis si
Trump est réélu. De plus en plus de gens
se rendent compte que nous sommes
confrontés à une urgence climatique.
Mais il y a aussi la question nucléaire.
Il y a plein de problèmes à l'échelle
mondiale et tous ces problèmes
surviennent en même temps. Il y a un
clivage énorme dans la société
américaine en raison de la présence de
Donald Trump à la Maison Blanche et les
États-Unis sont aussi clivés que ça peut
pas durer. Donc moi, je reste optimiste.
Je suis pas certain, je suis sûr de
rien, mais je suis optimiste et
pragmatique aussi. Et une des raisons
pour lesquelles j'ai écrit ce livre,
c'est pour
dire qu'il y a d'autres façons de faire.
Tout n'est pas
inventé. Non, c'est pas des
élucubrations de Joseph Sticklitz. Non,
il y a de vraies solutions qui
permettent d'améliorer
la qualité de vie malgré les ressources
limité.
Si votre génération, excusez-moi de dire
ça, mais la génération des vieux
continue à s'accrocher au pouvoir,
continue à utiliser tout son poids
politique, tous ses actifs financiers
pour maintenir ses ses acquis.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
Il y a
un climat générationnel
mais il y a quand même pas mal
d'individus
un peu âgés comme moi, comme Ellisabeth
Waren
il y a beaucoup de gens comme ça
qui
ne sont pas concernés par ce clivage
générationnel et qui se rendent bel et
bien compte
que c'est l'existence de notre
civilisation qui est en jeu,
l'existence de la vie humaine sur la
planète
qui est l'enjeu.
Le le conflit n'est pas entre
générations, il y a un conflit entre les
intérêt des sociétés des énergies
fossiles, les monopoles différentes
formes dans d'autres domaines, par
exemple le lobby des armes aux
États-Unis
et donc clivage par rapport au reste de
la société. Et ça on voit ça dans pas
mal d'études. 2/3/4 des gens veulent des
réglementations
pour les armes, veulent une meilleure
réglementation financière, veulent
euh moins d'inégalité,
veulent une augmentation du salaire
minimum.
Jusqu'à présent, on n' pas pu obtenir
cela.
Nous vivons dans une démocratie qui ne
fonctionne pas pour la majorité des gens
et on en prend conscience désormais. Et
moi, je reste optimiste. Quand je dis on
s'en rend compte et bien les jeunes s'en
rendent compte. Il y a pas mal de gens
de tous âges qui s'en rendent compte.
Et l'élection présidentielle de 2020
sera critique. Je croise les doigts bien
entendu.
Je prie, je fais tout ce qu'on peut. Je
fais des incantations.
Je veux que
les priorités progressistes l'emporte
parce que c'est l'avenir du pays qui est
en jeu. Mais l'enjeu va au-delà des
États-Unis bien entendu. C'est l'avenir
du monde qui est en jeu.
En terme de préconisation, est-ce que
vous pensez que la démographie doit être
encadrée ? Est-ce que le phénomène
d'avoir une démographie exponentielle
doit être encadré ? Est-ce que on doit
repenser notre conception à l'enfant ?
Est-ce qu'on doit repenser notre
conception à la famille ?
[Musique]
Une des conditions
nécessaires pour pouvoir vivre selon les
ressources limitées, c'est le contrôle
de la population
en Europe occidentale, au Japon,
en Chine,
c'est déjà le cas.
Et
la Chine a récemment mis fin à la
politique de l'enfant unique,
mais
la plupart des gens n'ont pas changé
leur comportement pour autant. Il y
avait des familles où où il y a deux
enfants, mais les Chinois vont pas se
lancer euh dans des familles à 5 ou 10
enfants. Donc
dans la plupart des pays du monde, le
problème de la démographie
exponentielle, comme vous dites, c'est
un problème qui a été résolu.
Et il y a un continent où ce où le
problème perdure, c'est l'Afrique.
[Musique]
Au cours des 70 ou 80 années à venir, on
estime que plus de 100 % de la
croissance de la force de travail de la
population
laborieuse aurait lieu en Afrique. Et ça
c'est un défi énorme,
mais on espère
que ce qu'on appelle la transition
démocraphique
selon laquelle plus les gens
s'enrichissent, ils ont plus de
possibilités économiques, les états
d'esprit changent. La transition
démographique en Asie et en Europe aura
également lieu en Afrique.
Ainsi, le résultat
sera que cette croissance démographique
exponentielle n'aura plus lieu d'être.
Hm.
Mais à à mon à mon avis, il faut un plan
marchal pour l'Afrique.
Il faut donner des opportunités
aux femmes notamment parce que s'ils ont
plus d'opportunités économiques,
ils décideront de ne plus avoir autant
d'enfants. Ça ça me paraît assz
Je voudrais vous poser une question et
avoir votre avis sur l'immigration.
et l'immigration et les réfugiés
climatiques et les réfugiés économiques.
Est-ce que le fait de faire des murs
arrêtera les gens ? Est-ce que le fait
de laisser les gens mourir en
Méditerranée
euh c'est une solution ? Est-ce que le
fait de ne pas apporter l'aide
suffisante sur place n'est pas un crime
contre l'humanité ?
Si si sur quoi on assiste, c'est un
crime contre l'humanité.
Et pour revenir aux États-Unis, si vous
le permettez,
le gouvernement Trump
résiste à toute mesure pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique alors
que le dérèglement climatique va générer
de plus en plus d'immigration
et va
accroître
le nombre de réfugiés climatiques des
gens qui vont fuir la désertification,
la famine et ainsi de suite. Aux
États-Unis, par exemple, nous sommes
confrontés au problème de l'immigration
du Guatemala. C'est pas un problème,
mais c'est une situation, c'est un
phénomène. Pourquoi les gens quittent-il
le Guatemala ? Et bien, c'est la famine.
Pourquoi il y a-il la famine ? Et bien,
c'est le réchauffement climatique.
Autrement dit,
les politiques de Trump causent le
problème dont il se plaint.
Les murs ne sont pas une solution.
Et la solution, il faut la trouver dans
les véritables causes, dans les raisons
pour lesquelles les gens décident de
migrer. C'est pourtant très clair.
Revenons 150 ans en arrière.
Pourquoi est-ce que les gens ont quitté
l'Irlande ? Il y a plus de gens
quitterai l'Irland. Il y a plus de de
gens d'origine irlandaise en dehors de
l'Irlande qu'il y a qu'il y en a en
Irlande. Pourquoi ils ont quitté
l'Irlande ? C'était la famine et la
politique économique. L'Irlande était
confrontée à la famine des pommes de
terre et pendant ce temps-là, les
propriétaires terriens exploitaient
exportaient les pommes de terre.
Donc c'est pas qu'on manquait de pommes
de terre, c'est qu'on manquait
d'égalité.
Le système était particulièrement
inégalitaire.
La terre était entre les mains de riches
britanniques
à l'époque. Donc cela ça illustre bien
les causes du problème. Que s'est-il
passé lorsque l'Irlande s'est enrichie ?
Et ben les Irlandais sont revenus et ils
ont cessé de quitter l'Irlande.
Moi, je suis allé en Irlande de
nombreuses fois et j'ai parlé avec plein
de gens, des personnes qui m'ont
expliqué que c'était pas une volonté des
irlandais de voir partir les jeunes.
C'était une nécessité économique qui les
a poussé à partir et le réchauffement
climatique lui va créer une nécessité
économique encore plus criante. C'est
pourquoi nous devons mettre fin au
dérèglement climatique et nous devons
créer des opportunités économiques là où
les gens souffrent. Passons à l'Europe,
passons à l'Allemagne. Est-ce que Est-ce
que le l'Allemagne n'est pas le Japon
d'autrefois
en terme de dette, de vieillissement de
la population, en terme de tous ces
facteurs ?
n'est pas en tête
les chiffres pour la démographie de
l'Allemagne, mais
du point de vue de la politique
économique, il faut bien comprendre que
l'Allemagne
exporte non seulement des automobiles,
mais force, elle oblige le reste de
l'Europe à mener des politiques
d'austérité. Gris,
la Grèce est un bon exemple.
Il y a aussi d'autres pays,
l'Irlande, le Portugal, l'Espagne
et le coût humain de l'austérité est
particulièrement élevé.
Donc c'est ça la grande problématique à
mes yeux.
Aujourd'hui, l'Allemagne connaît un
ralentissement et pas mal de gens
pensent qu'il va y avoir une récession
en Allemagne.
Le problème, c'est que l'Allemagne va
s'imposer la même chose qu'elle a imposé
au reste des de l'Europe.
Ils vont faire la même erreur plutôt que
de stimuler l'économie par la politique
fiscale. l'Allemagne va
vraisemblablement
continuer à mener ses politiques
d'austérité, de contraction
et on a plus on a plus de possibilités
de monétaire. La politique monétaire ce
n'est ça n'existe plus, c'est plus
possible. Donc c'est la politique
fiscale qui le relais et si l'Allemagne
ne réagit pas, le ralentissement en
Allemagne sera contagieux et il y aura
des retentissements dans le reste a un
président qui s'appelle Emmanuel Macron
et il a une théorie bien particulière,
ça s'appelle le ruissellement,
c'est-à-dire que il privilégie la upper
class et ça va ruisseler sur les autres
classes. Est-ce que vous y croyez ?
Est-ce que ce n'est pas du wishful
thinking ? Est-ce que ce n'est pas un
élément de langage ?
J'ai beaucoup écrit sur l'effet de
russellement.
Je parle du rellement dans pas mal
d'ouvrages, notamment le dernier.
Le rissellement, ce n'est qu'une
théorie, ça n'existe pas. Et il y a
énormément de données qui montrent que
ça ne marche pas. Parfois, je me dis que
ce serait bien si le risellement
fonctionnait parce que si le risellement
ça existait, si ça fonctionnait aux
États-Unis, il y aurait plus de problème
parce qu'on a donné tant d'argent aux
riches.
20 % des revenus ont été donnés à 1 % de
la population. 40 % de la richesse,
devrais-je dire, a été donné à 1 % de la
population. Si le ruisse allemand ça
existait, bien la classe moyenne
États-Unis serait tout à fait à l'aise
et les gens en bas de l'échelle se
porteraiit pas mal non plus. Mais en
réalité
90 % des Américains ont connu la
stagnation
alors que
1 % même un peu moins se portent
remarquablement bien.
Aujourd'hui, on a 40 ans de recul.
40 ans de recul par rapport au
néolibéralisme,
la politique économique de Rean,
de d'économie de l'offre. On a 40 ans de
recul de situation expérimentale avec ce
fameux ruissellement et désormais on
sait que ça ne marche pas.
Ça marche pour 0,1 % de la population
mais pas pour le reste de la société.
Je voudrais qu'on parle de Brexit, je
voudrais qu'on parle de dislocation
géopolitique mondiale. Je voudrais qu'on
parle de budget militaire.
Comment vous expliquez qu'aux
États-Unis, 54 % de vos impôts aillent
sur le budget militaire ? Comment vous
expliquez que la Grande-Bretagne
souhaite quitter l'Europe, qu'une partie
des des britanniques souhaitent quitter
l'Europe ? Et je voudrais enfin que vous
m'expliquiez ce que c'est la destruction
créatrice.
Ah voilà des questions plus vastes les
unes que les autres.
Votre première question,
c'est le l'argent du contribuable. qui
va dans le budget militaire. Et bien ça
c'est dû au fait que nos démocraties ne
fonctionnent pas bien. Il y a des
groupes d'intérêt
qui euh
influence voire forme nos politiques
économiques. Dans un de mes ouvrages,
j'explique que la guerre en Irak nous a
coûté des sommes incroyables.
J'ai dit dans ce livre 3000 milliards de
dollars. En réalité c'est 6. On a
dépensé 1000 milliards de dollars,
rien
qu'en coût de santé pour les soldats
revenus d'Irak et d'Afghanistan.
Plus de la moitié des militaires qui
sont revenus sont handicapés.
Ils souffrent de traumatisme
psychologique et de problèmes divers.
C'est varié. Donc un millier de
milliards de dollars pour couvrir les
coûts de santé et de handicap de nos
militaires là-bas. Donc des guerres
ultra onéreuses.
La guerre froide s'est terminé en 89
avec la chute du mur de Berlin. Mais nos
budgets militaires n'ont pas été réduits
pour autant comme si rien n'avait
changé. et Trump lui veut augmenter le
budget militaire.
Il
il dit que
les pays d'Europe dépensent 2 % de leur
PIB. Enfin, il voudrait que les pays
d'Europe dépensent 2 % de leur PIB en
budget militaire. Nous, nous dépensons
de l'argent pour avoir des armes qui ne
fonctionnent pas contre des ennemis qui
n'existent pas. Une bonne chose que les
ennemis n'existent pas parce que nos
armes ne fonctionnent pas. Si on avait
des vrais ennemis, là ce serait un
problème. Tout ça pour dire que on
subventionne le secteur de l'armement et
c'est symptomatique l'échec de notre
système politique. Dans un des chapitres
de mon livre, j'essaie de décrire le
fait que
il y a un mélange
de facteurs lié à l'inégalité
qui donne lieu à des inégalités
politiques et les règles sont conçues
pour avantager certains groupes de
pression des groupes économiques,
notamment le secteur de l'alarmement.
Donc tous les problèmes économiques et
politiques sont liés.
Voilà
la grande raison de cette dépense
dans le budget militaire. De quoi a
besoin notre société pour lutter contre
le dérèglement climatique, pour réduire
les inégalités, pour apporter une
protection sociale de qualité, pour
traiter les problèmes que nous avons
évoqué au début de notre conversation,
la désindustrialisation qui a des
conséquences des détaires et ainsi de
suite. On pourrait dépenser de manière
beaucoup plus profitable pour la
société. Vous avez également posé,
ça n'a pas été fait.
Je vais pas dire que les aux États-Unis,
il y a il reste encore des gens
intelligents.
Ça n'a pas été fait d'aider les pauvres,
de d'aider l'Afrique à grandir parce que
ça permettait ça mettait de la
concurrence à leur cast. Ça n'a pas été
fait parce que c'était potentiellement
des concurrents,
c'était potentiellement des ennemis. On
a maintenu l'Afrique dans un état de
infantilisé. On a maintenu l'Afrique
dans un état de conflit perpétuel pour
pouvoir se saisir de ses ressources. On
a maintenu la classe populaire à un
niveau très bas pour éviter de les voir
émerger à leur propre niveau. Est-ce que
c'était fait siamment ou c'était de la
passivité intellectuelle ?
[Musique]
Les politiques
envers l'Afrique comportent de nombreux
éléments. Tout d'abord, il est tout à
fait naturel de passer d'un système de
colonialisme à un système de
colonialisme économique.
Certains
voulaient
continuer à exploiter les ressources
naturelles.
Je vous donner un exemple.
structure tarifaire
était une était une structure
d'augmentation
et cette structure était conçue pour
s'assurer que l'Afrique continue à
fournir des ressources naturelles à
l'Europe et les autres pays qui
avancaient sans pouvoir développer un
tissu industriel
soi-même.
Donc
donc le nord a veillé à ses intérêts en
profitant du sud.
C'est pas tellement une peur de la
concurrence, c'était simplement un
passage de l'exploitation du
colonialisme
vers euh l'indépendance de ces pays mais
avec un colonialisme économique. Il y a
un autre élément qui est intervenu c'est
l'idéologie.
Comme on l'a dit précédemment, il y a
une période les années 80 où il y avait
Rean et Thaner au pouvoir et c'est là
que c'était le la naissance du
néolibéralisme.
On disait que les marchés fonctionnent
bien tout seul. Si un problème sur un
pays, c'est pas un problème des marchés,
c'est un problème du gouvernement. Le
gouvernement n'est pas la solution. Le
gouvernement est le problème, disait-on.
Donc euh après l'indépendance, le FMI a
imposé de nombreuses conditions à
l'Afrique alors que l'Afrique était
confrontée à une à des problèmes divers
et variés.
On manquait d'infrastructure, de
ressources, de capital humain et donc il
y avait pas suffisamment d'autonomie en
Afrique. L'un des
il y a un pays où il n'y avait que six
personnes avec un diplôme universitaire
au moment de l'indépendance et pourtant
il fallait qu'il se débrouille seul.
Donc le FMI et la Banque mondiale ont
imposé des politiques d'ajustement
structurel
et le résultat de ces politiques c'était
la désindustrialisation.
En 2000,
la proportion du PIB africain qui était
industriel était plus faible qu'en 1970.
Plutôt que de promouvoir la croissance
économique, ils avaient nuit à
l'Afrique.
Il y a des gens qui diraient que c'est
de la conspiration, que on visait à
faire du mal à nuire à l'Afrique.
Moi, j'ai tendance à penser que c'était
un
mélange de la continuité du colonialisme
économique
et une mauvaise idéologie.
stupidité si vous voulez, mais c'est
cette même idéologie
que l'Europe s'est imposé lorsqu'elle a
créé une BCE qui n'allait mettre
l'accent que sur l'inflation et ne pas
se préoccuper du chômage. C'est la même
idéologie
qui
s'est imposé
après la crise de 2008 selon laquelle on
a imposé l'austérité à la Grèce.
On pourrait dire que c'est une politique
mondiale. Vous êtes prêt à tuer votre
voisin et tuer l'Afrique en même temps.
Voyez
donc il y a deux interprétations
différentes.
Je crois que c'était un petit peu des
deux qui étaient à l'œuvre mais là on
voulait profiter de la Grèce aussi par
exemple. Donc tout ça pour dire que
c'est une combinaison de facteurs les
intérêts de certains qui instrumentalise
une idéologie pour servir leurs propres
intérêts. Juste euh on va passer sur le
Brexit.
Comment vous expliquez le Brexit et
comment vous expliquez cette dislocation
géopolitique mondiale ?
Pour comprendre le Brexit, il faut se
mettre dans le même état d'esprit euh
que pour essayer de comprendre Trump.
Il y a des sentiments féroces contre
l'establishment.
Il y a
une partie très importante de la
population qui pense que leurs intérêts
n'ont pas été servis. On leur a dit que
la mondialisation, la financiarisation
et la réduction des impôts des riches
euh permettrait de partager la
prospérité. On leur a venté les mérites
du ruissellement, mais ça ne fonctionne
pas, on l'a déjà dit. Donc,
est-ce que l'ablishment
était
mensongé ? Est-ce qu'il était bête ?
Mais
on n' pas eu confiance en
l'establishment. Voilà.
aux États-Unis et en Europe,
il y a eu ce sentiment, ce ressentiment
antiestablishment.
Tout n'est pas rationnel là-dedans,
hein. Les politiques de Trump vont
rendre
ses électeurs
euh
pire qu'avant. Donc, il va pas les
aider. On y assiste déjà. Les
allégements d'impôts n'aident pas ces
gens-là. Ces allègements d'impôts aident
les milliardaires aux États-Unis.
Donc aux États-Unis, voilà un démagogue
qui exploite, qui instrumentalise ce
mécontentement. Et au Royaume-Uni, il y
a à l'œuvre
les le même s le même genre de gens qui
instrumentalisent le mécontentement.
Bon, le Royaume-Unique
connaît un bouleversement absolument
incroyable. C'est l'incertitude totale
qui règne.
Néanmoins, on peut peut-être espérer
qu'on pourra éviter le Brexit
et on pourra éviter la dislocation qui
résulte du Brexit.
faire une petite parenthèse et parler
d'un autre sujet avant d'y retourner et
de retourner à nos sujets économiques.
Euh je voudrais vous poser une question
concernant Eddouard Snowon. Pour vous,
c'est un patriote ou c'est un traître ?
Oh patriote
Snowen
a
mis en lumière certaines activités du
gouvernement et ces activités étaient
nuisibles aux citoyens américains
et les Américains ont le droit de savoir
ce que fait le gouvernement.
On en revient à la nécessité de la
transparence.
Et il est très clair que Snowden
n'était pas motivé par le lucre, était
pas guidé par l'argent. C'est parce que
en son fort intérieur, il pensait faire
ce qu'il fallait faire.
Il lui a fallu un courage immense.
Il lui a fallu également beaucoup de
compétences pour faire ce qu'il a fait.
Je comprends
pourquoi Obama ne l'a pas remercié
d'avoir divulgué tous les secrets du
gouvernement américain. Je crois que
Obama a eu tort de faire de Snowen
ennemi.
Snowden, il faut le traiter comme un
lanceur d'alerte. D'ailleurs, Snowen
était un lanceur d'alerte.
Il a expliqué que le gouvernement
faisait des choses cachées
et qui ne sont pas bonnes pour les
citoyens.
Euh qui a été en prison parce que
suspecté de protéger Julien Assange.
Les Américains ont quelle perception de
ces Wils Blowers ? Est-ce que les
Américains souhaitent qu'on les protège
mieux ? où il y a pardonnez-moi
l'expression un je m'en foutisme
caractérisé.
Ah non, il y a pas de je m'en footisme.
Non non, les Américains euh
soutiennent les lanceurs d'alerte. sans
lanceur d'alerte,
on est trop tenté lorsqu'on est au
pouvoir
de
continuer à ne pas révéler les choses
inavoes. J'ai beaucoup écrit sur le
secret. Parfois les raisons de maintenir
les choses secrètes sont légitimes, mais
le plus souvent les raisons ne sont pas
bonnes. Patrick Mam a écrit un
formidable livre dont le titre est
Secrecy et il explique dans cet ouvrage
que
une des conséquences de garder des
informations secrètes, c'est que la
guerre froide a duré bien plus longtemps
qu'elle n'aurait pu ou dû durer
si on avait eu plus d'informations sur
l'Union Soviétique. Si l'Union
Soviétique a plus d'informations sur les
États-Unis, et bien la guerre froide
aurait pris une tournure toute autre,
elle aurait été plus courte. Les gens
qui sont au pouvoir
sont tentés de cacher ce qu'ils font,
non seulement lorsqu'ils ont fait
quelque chose d'illégal, mais quand ils
se trompent aussi.
Si vous êtes au pouvoir, vous voulez pas
euh que l'on révèle vos erreurs. Donc ce
n'est pas simplement des agissements
illégaux dont il s'agit. Il s'agit
également de d'erreurs. Parfois on se
trompe et malheureusement les gens au
pouvoir ont tendance à vouloir cacher
tout cela.
À l'heure actuelle,
nous vivons une époque aux États-Unis où
nous sommes en train de d'apprécier
les lanceurs d'alerte. C'est en effet un
lanceur d'alerte qui a signalé que Trump
avait essayé
de faire en sorte que l'Ukraine
donne des informations contre le fils de
Joe Biden.
Nous, on aurait pas eu connaissance de
ça s'il y avait pas eu un lanceur
d'alerte pour nous le dire. que Edward
Snow est trouvé asile en Russie.
Quelle a été la votre perception de ça ?
Et comment expliquez-vous que ce soit la
Russie qui protège un de vos patriotes ?
Et bien une des explications,
c'est que
la Russie
aime bien être le trublion.
Donc la Russie était intervenue dans
l'élection en 2016 aux États-Unis. il
semblerait qu'elle soit intervenue dans
certaines élections européennes.
Donc, on se rend compte que
Snowden a fait des choses gênantes pour
les États-Unis. Snowden a mis en lumière
le fait que le gouvernement américain
agissait à l'encontre de ses propres
citoyens.
Mais est en Russie surtout parce
qu'Obama
a pris des mesures très fortes plus
plutôt que d'aller dans un autre pays ou
plutôt que de le protéger en tant que
lanceur d'alerte Obama.
[Musique]
euh
décidé qu'il ne fallait pas que le
peuple sache ce que le gouvernement
fait. La Chine, la Russie
euh
qui s'allie
est-ce que c'est le fait que les
États-Unis soient dans un comportement
complètement psychotique avec sa
capacité à gérer l'économie mondiale et
à gérer le dollar ?
Est-ce que la la dédolarisation du monde
a commencé ? Est-ce que on va arriver à
à
à mettre les États-Unis cette politique
psychotique avec les injections de
liquidité sur le banc pour éviter la
crise ou est-ce que c'est simplement une
réaction psychosomatique ou une réaction
symptomatique ?
Trump a provoqué des dégâts énormes.
L'ordre économique
se trouve dans une situation bien pire
en raison de trempilement de même pour
l'économie américaine.
pas rompu des accords
simplement
parce qu'il n'était pas Obama.
L'Iran n'avait pas
rompu l'accord.
Les autres partis qui ont signé l'accord
l'ont dit. L'Iran a respecté l'accord.
Les États-Unis n'ont jamais présenté
l'épreuve de la rupture de l'accord par
l'Iran. Donc
autrement dit, vous utilisez le terme
psychotique mais on peut dire que les
politiques de Trump manquent de
cohérence. Elles sont incohérentes,
elles sont ératiques. Donc à un moment
donné, il peut menacer
d'attaquer la Corée du Nord alors que le
lendemain le Vel et chemise avec
le chef nord-coréen.
Un jour, il décide d'augmenter les
tarifsigners sur les produits chinois.
Le lendemain, il change d'avis. Donc
c'est une girouette, c'est pas de la
politique économique.
Mais le fondement de l'économie,
c'est
le
le fondement de sa politique économique,
c'est le refus du multilatéralisme.
Donc les États-Unis d'abord,
tous les autres après.
Et cela ne peut pas constituer
une base saine d'un bon ordre
économique. Donc dans ce contexte, il
est naturel que les pays se demandent
comment aller de l'avant. On ne peut pas
faire confiance aux États-Unis. Nous
devons
trouver d'autres dispositions
économiques.
Donc nous vivons une époque
de réalignement économique en quelque
sorte.
Donc ce n'est pas surprenant
de voir que la Chine se tourne vers la
Russie mais vers d'autres régions du
monde aussi.
[Musique]
Les États-Unis sont devenus tellement
nombrilistes que son influence a diminué
dans toutes les autres régions du monde.
Autrement dit, s'il un problème,
la coopération
à laquelle les États-Unis devraient
faire appel ne sera peut-être pas au
rendez-vous. On a vu un exemple
récemment où les
les États-Unis étaient très mécontents
des attaque sur les contre les champs
pétroliers saoudien. Mais personne ne
sera lié à la bannière de Trump pour
aller combattre l'Iran. Non.
Si si je vous dis,
[Musique]
ça vous fait penser à quoi ?
rendre les individus mais aussi les
nations esclaves
dans le passé.
Il y a pas mal individus qui étaient
des esclaves de fête, des gens endettés
qui étaient
obligés de travailler
pour rembourser leur dette. Donc ces
gens-là pe renoncer à leur liberté.
Et donc les individus et les pays
peuvent perdre leur liberté lorsque ils
sont trop endettés.
La plupart des pays
dans le champ de leur politique
économique interdisent le travail forcé
et si il y a une dette excessive qu'on
ne peut pas rembourser et ben on déclare
faillite et la tête est effacée.
[Musique]
Et en fait,
l'emprunteur aurait dû
faire attention, mais le prêteur aurait
dû faire attention aussi. Donc le
prêteur et l'emprunteur sont tous deux
coupables d'une situation de faillite
dans
un ouvrage précédent et dans celui-ci,
j'explique que les États-Unis
ont remis en place le travail forcé si
vous ne pouvez pas faire face à votre
endettement
plutôt
que de se déclarer en faillite, on peut
désormais vous obliger à verser 25 % de
revenus pour le restant de vos jours.
Donc, c'est une espèce de servitude
partielle, de mise en servitude
partielle. Pire encore, si un jeune
américain américaine reprennent de
l'argent pour aller à la fac parce que
les fac américaines, on le sait, sont
très très chères. La dette des étudiants
est de 25000 30000 dollars
et la dette étudiants au total se monte
à 1,5 milliers de milliards de dollars.
Les banques ont fait en sorte qu'une loi
soit promulguée pour que cette dette ne
soit pas effacée même si on déclare
faillite. Et si un parent se porte
garant
et si l'enfant meurt d'une maladie ou
d'un accident, et bien le parent ne peut
pas faire effacer la dette. Autrement
dit, les parents sont pieds et points
liés pour le restant de leur jour.
Ça c'est la loi sur les faillites aux
États-Unis. Mais il y a pas de loi à
l'échelle internationale. Donc si un
pays en prenne plus qu'il ne peut
rembourser,
le FMI a payé prêté plus de 50 milliards
de dollars à l'Argentine. L'Argentine
pourra vraisemblablement pas rembourser
ce montant. Pas rapidement. En tout cas,
il n'existe pas de loi internationale
sur la faillite et pourtant c'est
nécessaire. Encore une fois, j'ai
expliqué cela dans un de mes ouvrages.
Quand j'étais président du comité
des conseiller aux Nations- Unies, les
Nations- Unies ont fait voter des
dispositions sur les faillites et cela a
fait l'objet d'un soutien de très
nombreux pays, à l'exception des
États-Unis et d'autres grands pays
prêteurs.
Autrement dit,
à l'échelle des pays, il n'y a pas de
solution facile à l'endettement. Il y a
quelques pays qui ont dit "Nous nous
n'allons pas vous laisser nous
étrangler". Mais la plupart des pays
deviennent
de fait étouffés
et perdent leur indépendance économique
lorsque
l'endettement est excessif.
Dans la Constitution américaine,
il y a une partie où les États-Unis
peuvent répudier leur dettes. Est-ce que
vous pensez un jour que les États-Unis
vont répudier leur dette ?
lo sont faillites mais aujourd'hui il
faut la réformer cette loi.
Il y a de bonnes dispositions. Il y a ce
que l'on appelle le chapter 11, une
société qui ne peut pas repayer ses
dettes.
peut-être tout faire l'objet d'une
restructuration
mais il est
mieux de préserver les emplois et de
préserver le rôle économique de
l'entreprise.
Encore une fois, ça revient à la notion
selon laquelle le prêteur a eu tort de
prêter autant d'argent. Donc dans la loi
américaine, il y a cette loi qui
s'appelle Chapter 11 et pas mal de pays
qui ont adopté des lois similaires. Mais
cette disposition n'existe pas pour les
gouvernements.
Ainsi, les gouvernements ne peuvent pas
restructurer leurs dettes facilement.
Et aux États-Unis, nous avons un gros
problème avec notre colonie entre
guillemets qui est Porto Rico.
On va dire Porto Rico,
vous n'êtes pas
couvert par les disposition
de sur la faillite pour les villes
américaines par exemple, mais vous êtes
une colonie mais vous n'avez pas le
droit de passer de faire voter votre
propre loi sur les faillites. Donc on
traite le Porto Rico comme une colonie
et le résultat
c'est que les Portoor Ricains souffrent
énormément.
Porto Rico aurait dû avoir la
possibilité de restructurer sa dette
pour ne plus être endetté de manière
excessive.
Donc cela montre clairement les
conséquences
de l'absence d'une bonne loi sur la
faillite.
Je voudrais je voudrais votre avis sur
le phénomène de sanction économique.
Est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose ?
Est-ce que c'est complètement
contre-productif ? Est-ce que c'est
productif ou est-ce que ça ne l'a jamais
été ?
un cas, les sanctions ont été utiles et
productives, mais il faut manier les
sanctions avec délicatesse.
Les sanctions ont joué un grand rôle
pour mettre fin à la partaille en
Afrique du Sud, pour mettre fin au
régime en Redésie du Sud.
La
menace des sanctions
commerciales ont joué
un rôle dans l'accord mondial visant à
éliminer
les gaz qui détruisent la couche de
zone.
Donc là, les sanctions ont été
couronnées de succès.
Aujourd'hui
euh il n'y a plus ce problème de trou
dans la couche euh d'ozone. Donc dans
certains cas, les sanctions, ça
fonctionne bien. Mais encore une fois,
il faut les manier
avec délicatesse.
Si on revient à l'Afrique du Sud, il y
avait un accord,
un consensus
qui disait que la PIDE c'est mal et donc
le consensus était à l'échelle mondiale
en fait.
Aujourd'hui,
malheureusement
les circonstances ont il aurait dû y
avoir un consensus mondial
des situations où les sanctions ont pas
été appliquées avec rigueur. Parfois
les sanctions ne suffisent pas à changer
les politiques. salaire universel,
le salaire universel par exemple chaque
nouveau nez va avoir l'équivalent pour
un toit et manger
à vie pour tout le monde.
Je suis économiste. Je pense qu'il faut
des mesures d'incitation.
S'il n'y a pas de mesure d'incitation,
on est confronté à des problèmes
économiques et ou sociaux. Regardez
nombre de pays dans le monde, les pays
pétroliers par exemple. Là, on donne
un montant d'argent considérable aux
citoyens
alors que en fait, c'est pas le bonheur
qui règne dans ces pays. Les jeunes
hommes qui ont de l'argent mais qui
n'ont pas d'emploi ne sont pas heureux.
Et lorsqu'ils ne sont pas heureux,
ils se lancent dans des activités
contre-productives.
Donc moi, il m'a paraît que la vraie
responsabilité des gouvernements
aujourd'hui est de s'assurer que tous
les gens qui
peuvent avoir un emploi doivent avoir un
emploi.
C'est ce sur quoi nous devons mettre
l'accent. Je parle ça, je parle de ça
dans mon livre. Ça devrait être une
obligation pour les gouvernements
l'assurance d'avoir un emploi.
On va parler d'une partie relativement
importante et novatrice, les
cryptonnaies.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner vos
pensées autour des cryptomonnaies ?
Votre
votre avis ?
communauté internationale au cours des
25 dernières années
pour obtenir plus de transparence dans
le système financier.
On n'a pas atteint la perfection, nous
l'avons dit, mais plus de transparence
plus de transparence pour éviter le
blanchiment, pour
lutter contre la corruption, les
stupéfiants
et les activités illicites d'une façon
générale et l'élévation fiscale aussi.
À mes yeux, il est
inconcevable
que
il est incroyable de penser que que le
fait que ça soit sur une plateforme
électronique, ça suffit à résoudre tous
les problèmes. Vous pouvez faire ce que
vous voulez à condition que ça soit sur
une plateforme numérique totalement
absurde.
Libra, l'initiative lancée par Facebook
et illustre les contradictions.
Libra se décrit comme une cryptoevise.
Mais lorsque on critique Libra,
on dit on n pas besoin de choses encore
plus secrètes pour permettre les
activités illicites.
Les gens de Facebook vous disent que
Libra ça va être une cryptodevise
transparente. Mais c'est un oxyor.
Crypto et transparent, ça va pas
ensemble dans la même phrase. C'est un
oxymor, c'est impossible.
Donc pour moi, les devises sont bonnes.
Nous avons de bonnes devises. Le dollar
c'est une bonne devise
pour nous
et pour le reste du monde.
Si on mène les réformes de l'euro tell
que celle que je décrit, l'euro serait
une bonne devise aussi. On peut faire de
l'euro une bonne devise.
Le problème de Libra et des cryptodises,
c'est que ces devises veulent un
mécanisme de paiement plus
concurrentiel. Ça nous ramène au
problème du pouvoir des monopoles et le
dysfonctionnement du système financier.
Le système financier
a exploité son monopole sur les moyens
de payant de paiement pour euh générer
des milliards de dollars euh de
bénéfices en rendant les opérations plus
chères. Il nous faut des mécanismes de
paiement euh low cost avec des coûts
très faibles.
Donc
les le les peuples, le pouvoir et les
prophics, c'est le titre de mon livre.
On exploite
les autres pour dégager des bénéfices
pour soi-même. Et ce qu'il nous faut,
c'est une réglementation publique pour
empêcher
ces activités délétaires. Il faut plus
de concurrence s'agissant des moyens de
paiement.
Et si on ne peut pas faire en sorte que
le marqué soit concurrentiel, peut-être
que le gouvernement devra intervenir.
J'aimerais qu'on aborde tout ce qui est
technopir, les gafas comme on les
appelle en France, Google, Amazon,
Facebook et et bien d'autres maintenant.
Euh est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur que
ce technouvoir
devienne un état dans l'état ?
Si je me préoccupe du pouvoir excessif
excessif de ces entreprises.
Les entreprises les plus riches sont
plus riches que certains pays.
tris abus, le monopole,
l'exploitation de nos données privées,
et l'exploitation de ce pouvoir
pour intervenir dans le système
politique de manière à ne pas payer
l'impôt.
Une des choses frappantes chez ces
gafas,
c'est
le fait qu'elle ne paye pas leur part
des impôts.
Ils sont très innovants
en matière fiscale aussi. L'Irlande
c'est l'exemple criant.
Donc il y a des
bénéfices générés en Europe. Ces
entreprises ont prétendu que les profits
étaient générés en Irlande puis il a été
signé un accord secret avec l'Irlande
pour que la fiscalité soit très faible.
0,02
% pour autant que je me souvienne de
leur bénéfice.
Donc l'Irlande en l'occurrence
voler les revenus fiscaux des autres
pays d'Europe.
C'est pas un très bon partenariat si
vous voulez mon avis.
Mais l'Europe et l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale do s'assurer
que toutes les multinationales payent
leur part d'impôts.
Et la mesure prise par la France
en imposant ces entreprises a permis
d'ouvrir le débat tout le moins.
Il y a eu l'exemple de l'Irlande et
maintenant la France a dit et ben on
pourra leur faire payer au moins un
petit quelque chose. C'est peut-être pas
à la hauteur de ce qu'ils doivent payer
mais au moins ils payeront un petit
quelque chose.
Revenons à ma première question initiale
qui était la destruction créatrice,
cette fameuse théorie chumpetorienne.
Ça existe, ça n'existe pas, ça n'est pas
du pardonnez-moi mais du bullshit.
C'est
l'innovation c'est important.
Pourquoi la qualité de vie s'est-elle
améliorée par rapport il y a 250 ans ?
Il y a 250 ans, les gens devaient
dépenser
par se consacrer toute leur vie pour
s'alimenter, se vêtir pour se loger.
La vie était brève,
la vie était dure.
Pourquoi
la qualité de vie est-elle meilleure
aujourd'hui ? La réponse, c'est
l'innovation.
Il y a eu de nombreuses innovations.
C'est la science qui nous fait avancer.
Et dans mon livre, je critique notamment
parce qu'il essaie de nuire à la
science, il essaie de faire reculer
notre civilisation de connaissance. Et
ça c'est une des grandes critiques que
l'on peut faire à Trump.
Ça c'est un effet à long terme qu'il est
en train d'avoir. Ça c'est très
important.
Et par ailleurs innovation après
innovation
forcer des gens à changer activité.
Lorsque ce processus a commencé,
plus de 70 % de la population était
agréaire. On était dans une civilisation
agraire. Aujourd'hui,
il y a 2 à 3 % de population qui
produit plus d'aliments qu'une société
obèse ne peut en consommer. Donc, il
nous faut une transition.
Et dans cette transition, on peut
l'appeler
la destruction créative si vous voulez,
mais la leçon clé que l'on peut retirer,
c'est que le gouvernement doit jouer un
rôle important. Il faut que les gens qui
ont perdu leur emploi trouvent une autre
subsistance.
Donc, les gens qui ont perdu leur emploi
agricole sont passés dans le secteur
industriel. Ça c'était lors de la 2è
guerre mondiale. Aujourd'hui, on a moins
d'industrie, on passe dans une économie
de service et donc il nous faudra
une intervention plus forte de l'État.
Donc des politiques industrielles, des
politiques de
main d'œuvre, d'emploi et ainsi de suite
pour mener cette transition. Et cette
transition que nous appelons de nos
vœux, c'est la transition verte. Euh on
reviendra sur la la transition verte et
et tous ces éléments de langage autour
de la transition verte. Je voudrais
qu'on parle de Jaret Diamonds euh et de
la théorie de l'effondrement. Est-ce que
vous avez lu ce son ce son livre ?
Est-ce que vous êtes
magnifique.
On voit l'île de Pâqu où l'on abat le
dernier arbre.
et où on sait que l'on pourra pas
construire de bateaux pour aller pêcher.
Quelle image ! Quelle image ! C'est ce
que nous vivons aujourd'hui.
Ce livre de Jarette Dianmond
cette image avec tant de puissance.
Le système capitaliste peut
s'autoétruire
si on l'arrête pas.
Non, ce n'est pas trop tard.
Et la dernière phrase de mon livre,
c'est que nous devons sauver le
capitalisme de ces
On va prendre quelques questions
d'internet.
La première que je vois passer. Que
pensent-il de l'envoler du cours de l'or
? Y a-t-il selon lui un rapport direct
avec les injections de liquidité récente
? Est-ce que cela ne sent-il pas un peu,
excusez-moi le mot, la merde ?
surtout lorsque les incertitudes sont
énormes,
lorsque les gens pense à tort que l'or
est un
arbre re de sécurité, on ne sait pas ce
qui va venir du côté de la politique
monétaire ou du côté des guerres
commerciales,
la guerre en Iran éventuellement. Donc
l'or a toujours été considéré comme une
valeur refuge, une sorte de dernier
recours face à la internet de
Raspoutine.
Joseph Stiglitz aurait déclaré que ceux
que ce sont les pays qui sortiront les
premiers de l'euro qui s'en sortiront le
mieux peut-il expliquer ce point de vue
?
Euh ce que j'ai dit plus précisément,
c'est que
l'euro
a généré des contraintes énormes sur des
pays comme la Grèce ou l'Italie.
Donc une devise unique qui a
retiré les taux de change et la
souplesse qui va avec, la souplesse des
taux d'intérêt,
les instruments d'ajustement
sans pour autant apporter de d'éléments
de remplacement. Donc là, il y a un
problème de conception de l'euro
et la grande recommandation que je
formule, c'est la réforme de l'euro
pour que la devise unique fonctionne.
Il y a pas mal de pays en Europe qui se
rendent compte que la réforme est
nécessaire et qu'il faut une union
bancaire par exemple.
On parle beaucoup de l'Union bancaire en
2015.
et l'Union bancaire, c'était surtout une
assurance de dépôt commune.
Malheureusement,
une fois
la crise envolée pour ainsi dire le
débat sur les réformes nécessaires pour
que l'euro fonctionne ont disparu aussi.
Ainsi, les réformes n'ont pas eu lieu.
Donc à mon sens,
il est possible voire probable qu'il y
aura une autre crise. Je ne saurais pas
vous dire quand et l'Europe n'a pas la
souplesse lui permettant de réagir de
manière efficace.
Si l'Europe réagit par l'austérité en
obligeant la Grèce à entrer dans une
récession importante,
moi je comprends qu'un gouvernement
puisse dire plutôt que de prendre ce
type de médicament qui va nous tuer et
qui va pas nous permettre de recouvrir
la prospérité où les jeunes sont obligés
de quitter le pays pour trouver un
emploi où les familles sont décomposées
séparées Oui,
peut-être qu'il serait plus
recommandable de quitter l'Eure. Euh,
est-ce que pour Joseph le craque est
imminent ?
non, il y a un ralentissement à n'en pas
douter.
Donc le ralentissement n'est pas
imminent, il est actuel mais la crise de
avait des éléments très distinctifs.
Les banques notamment aux États-Unis
ont pris des risques incommensurable et
ont mené des
politiques fruleuses énormes.
Aujourd'hui, la réglementation est
meilleure, pas aussi bonne qu'elle
devrait l'être, mais la réglementation
est meilleure. Les banques sont mieux
réglementées.
Et donc la probabilité
de d'une crise n'est pas immense. Pas
pour l'instant du moins. Néanmoins, il
faut bien comprendre que le système
bancaire n'est guerre transparent et il
y a beaucoup de gens qui ont été surpris
de l'injection de 75 milliards de
dollars par la fin de la semaine
dernière. Cela indique il y a des choses
qui vont peut-être pas si bien que ça,
mais
les 75 milliards de dollars ont été
injectés et les marchés financiers se
sont stabilisés. Bien,
encore une fois, l'iminence est peu
probable. L'iminence d'une crise est peu
probable, mais il faut reconnaître qu'il
y a un manque de transparence.
Une question plus personnelle. Est-ce
que vous pensez pas que la Fed et la BCE
ou la BOJ se transforme en bas de banque
?
Ces banques centrales ont été créées
pour être des prêteurs de derniers
recours pour réguler les banques, pour
empêcher les banques de se lancer dans
des risques excessifs
ou de s'engager dans des comportements
euh peu louables.
Les banques centrales ont répondu à
certaines de ces fonctions, pas de
manière parfaite, mais pas de manière
nulle non plus.
À certaines époques, les banques
centrales n'ont pas bien fait leur
boulog.
Je vous parle des quelques années avant
la crise de 2008, principal ont mené des
mesures désastreuse
et le monde a payé un tribut économique
énorme et nous sommes en train de payer
le tribut politique de leur agissement
peu éclairé. Mais
entre 2008 et disons 2016,
est-ce qu'on aurait été
mieux si on avait pas eu de banque
centrale ?
Je dirais non. La situation serait pire
si on avait pas les banques.
Une question de Miretzaki.
Connaissez-vous le montant global de
dette au taux négatif aujourd'hui ? On
est à 15000 milliards de dollars contre
6000 milliards de dollars il y a
seulement 1 an.
Une part de plus de plus en plus
importante de cette dette touche donc
des intérêts négatifs de 0 de - 0 35 %
en moyenne. Une petite catastrophe pour
les caisses de pension selon Exè
dérivative qui conseille d'investir dans
l'or. Est-ce que les taux négatifs ne
sont pas un aveu d'impuissance ?
négatif, c'est indicatif
du fait que les banques centrales
n'ont pas pris toute la mesure de la
complexité des conséquences de leurs
agissements.
J'ai évoqué
comment le
les inégalités sont le résultat du
quantitative easing parce que ça la
bourse a augmenté
et les plusvalues sur les titres sont
perçus par 1 % de la population.
J'explique comment les retraités
souffrent de tout cela.
La Fed et la BCE
sont dans une position fort délicate en
raison de la doctrine de l'austérité.
Ce qu'on aurait dû faire aux États-Unis
et en Europe,
c'est plus d'expansion fiscale.
[Musique]
Et en l'absence de cette expansion
fiscale, toute la charge de la
stimulation de l'économie
a été sur les épaules des banques
centrales. Au bout du compte, il faut
poser des questions difficiles.
Que se serait-il passé si les taux
d'intérêt n'avait pas été baissé ? Et
bien
là, il y aurait une calamité financière
énorme. Il y a une autre question
de passer de
1 % à - 0,35 %. Est-ce que ça fait du
bien ça ? Moi je dirais non.
Voilà, ça fait très peu de bien par
rapport au coût social
qu'il faut supporter, les retraités par
exemple et ainsi de suite. Donc
la banque centrale européenne et la Fed
aurait dû crier.
Nous avons besoin de stimulation
fiscale.
Notre politique monétaire
a des conséquences trop rudes sur la
société, il faut faire plus sur le plan
fiscal d'intérêt vont remonter
à ce stade, je dirais que
si on passe de - 0,35 à 10 ans + 1
Les conséquences ne seront pas
tangibles.
Particulièrement si cela a lieu
simultanément dans tous les pays. Si
c'est le fait d'un seul pays
et ben ça va nuire au taux de change et
donc ça va nuire aux exportations et ça
va nuire à l'économie du pays. Et si
tous les pays agissent de concert, et
bien il y aura pas d'impact lié au taux
de change.
Par conséquent, les conséquences
délétaires ne seront pas très
importantes.
[Musique]
Il y aura néanmoins des conséquences
si les taux d'intérêt passent à 5 6 %
parce que étant donné l'endettement aux
États-Unis par exemple
sous Trump on arrive à un déficit de un
milliers de milliers de milliards de
dollarsin.
Donc
voilà, de l'argent qu'on aurait pu
dépenser en infrastructure ou en autre
chose. Et s'il y a un taux d'intérêt
important sur une dette pareil,
évidemment ça va créer beaucoup de
pression sur la situation de l'économie.
Donc si les taux d'intérêt augmentent de
manière importante, l'Europe sera
confrontée à une crise. Oui.
Une question d'exoidère-t-il
Julien Assange comme un lanceur d'alerte
?
Le rôle de Juliana est devenu assez
ambivalent.
La divulgulation de certains courriels
d'Hillary Clinton semble montrer qu'il
était en collusion avec l'administration
de Trump et avec la Russie pour
mettre à la démocratie aux États-Unis.
Donc être un lanceur d'alerte, c'est une
chose, mais nuire à la démocratie, c'est
autre chose. C'était au départ, c'est à
la suite de sa vidéo collatérale des
mage où on voyait des des crimes de
l'armée américaine sur des civils
iraakins.
Est-ce que au départ c'était pas un
lanceur d'alerte ?
au sujet qu'on a évoqué plusieurs fois
dans cette conversation, la transparence
et le secret.
Il y a des conditions, par exemple une
situation de guerre où on ne veut pas
divulguer euh
nos nos intentions.
Où est-ce qu'on va débarquer en
Normandie ? On va pas vous le dire quand
même. Et il en va de même
si vous avez des gens qui travaillent
pour vous et qui seront torturés si on
donne des noms. Donc il y a des choses
qu'il faut éviter. fait mais le fait que
l'armée américaine torturait
oui
des informations sur des choses qu'il ne
faut pas faire comme la torture, ça
c'est important. C'est pourquoi il faut
agir avec circons
provoquer de la torture en donnant des
informations. Il faut pas provoquer la
bord de quiconque en donnant des
informations. Pourtant, il faut de la
responsabilisation et de la
transparence. C'est une histoire
d'équilibre qu'il faut trouver. et un
songe quant à lui est allé disons
au-delà de ce qu'il fallait du
alors une question un peu compliquée la
situation actuelle taux d'intérêt
négatif et zéro croissance
n'infirme-t-elle pas les présupposés
fondamentaux de son école de pensée
postkénésianisme selon lui
pourquoi est-ce que ça remettrait en
question ma façon de voir les choses.
Si on avait une bonne politique fiscale
pour stimuler l'économie,
on ne serait pas dans la situation
actuelle avec des taux d'intérêt négatif
et très peu de croissance. et le fait
que la politique fiscale nous permette
de sortir
de cette situation dans laquelle on est
embourbé aujourd'hui, c'est tout à fait
cohérent
avec la politique kenzienne tout à fait
ou la pensée kenne tout à fait.
Une question de Moira. Que pensent-il de
Christine Lagarde en tant que présidente
du FMI ?
Ah bah Christine la garde, elle va avoir
un gros défi à relever.
[Musique]
Certaines politiques qui seront
nécessaires pour permettre à l'Europe de
continuer à aller de l'avant sont remis
en question par l'Allemagne et la
situation en Allemagne et en Italie sur
le plan politique et économique sont
différentes.
Et
pour que l'euro fonctionne,
il faut que l'euro fonctionne pour des
pays où il y a des disparités énormes,
non seulement du point de vue
économique, mais aussi
du point de vue de la philosophie
économique.
Autrement dit, il faudra qu'elle fasse
montre d'une grande compétence
diplomatique pour que ça fonctionne.
Christine Lagarde a très bien géré les
complexités du FMI.
Donc,
on peut avoir bon espoir qu'elle
arrivera à gérer ses complexités en
Europe.
Question de Thba-t-il aujourd'hui,
pensent-il qu'aujourd'hui les USA
sont-ils encore une démocratie ?
Voilà une question ardue.
Je voudrais pouvoir vous dire oui, mais
je vais vous dire ceci.
Une démocratie parfaite, ça n'existe
pas.
Mais au cours des dernières années, les
Américains ont pris conscience des
dégâts provoqués à la démocratie. deux
euh deux euh présidents ont été élus
sans une majorité des électeurs.
On a voté pour des
parlementaires. On ne contrôle pas le
Sénat aux États-Unis, vous le savez.
Mais maintenant, les démocrates sont au
pouvoir à la chambre des représentants.
Il y a un découpage électoral mais la
Cour suprême dit "Ah, c'est pas un
problème de démocratie, c'est un
problème politique."
Donc si on a
un découpage
électoral,
comment corriger le découpage électoral
de manière politique alors que la Cour
suprême vous dit que c'est un problème
politique et qu'elle veut pas s'occuper
du l'aspect juridique de la chose,
autrement dit du découpage électoral,
c'est un cercle vicieux aux États-Unis.
Il y a trop d'argent en plus dans la
politique. Le rôle des entreprises est
beaucoup trop important aux États-Unis.
Il y a le fait que l'on élimine le
nombre de lecteurs, on limite le nombre
de lecteurs. Dans mon livre, j'explique
tous ces problèmes
auxquels notre démocratie est
confrontée. Et de surcroix, il y a
d'autres problèmes dans notre
démocratie. Les Républicains essayent
de
d'enchaîner la démocratie.
Nous pensions avoir un système où
c'était la majorité qui pouvait régner
mais avec des droits pour la minorité.
Aujourd'hui, c'est la minorité qui règne
et la majorité veut plus d'égalité, veut
des lois sur les armes, veut
meilleur réglementation
dans divers domaines et c'est impossible
à obtenir.
Par conséquent,
les États-Unis connaissent une époque
politique particulièrement
difficile. Néanmoins, redisons-le. Nous
avons une élection présidentielle en
et moi j'espère vivement
que il y aura de nombreux électeurs
attachés à la démocratie qui iront
mettre leur bulletin dans l'erne et que
dans l'urne et que nous réussirons à
restaurer la démocratie aux États-Unis.
Est-ce que vous voulez aborder un sujet
en particulier avec nous ?
Chose quand même. On a tout
Alors, on arrive à la fin à la fin de
notre interview. On a pour habitude de
poser de demander à notre invité de nous
conseiller trois livres et de laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Il y a un livre que je recommande,
c'est Democracy
Nancy Min.
Il y a d'autres livres
qui portent sur la démocratie,
comment la démocratie est morte. Il y en
a d'autre
qui est l'anatomie du fascisme.
Là, c'est l'avènement du fascisme,
livre rédigé en 2005,
mais on a l'impression qu'il a été
rédigé l'année dernière et qu'il décrit
Trump. Voilà des ouvrages
dont la lecture vous donnera
[Musique]
non seulement une compréhension des
difficultés du de la politique mais des
interactions entre la politique et
l'économie.
Hitler n'a jamais été élu par la
majorité.
Il avait quoi ? 30 % de soutien Hitler.
Mais c'est la
collaboration des entreprises et des
conservateurs qui ont dit ne vous
inquiétez pas, nous allons le maîtriser.
Et c'est ainsi qu'hitler est devenu
chancelier. Et puis c'est ce qui s'est
passé par la suite. Et aux États-Unis,
on a assisté à la collaboration des
Républicains
qui ont donné le pouvoir à Trump et qui
lui ont permis à
qui lui ont permis de se lancer dans ces
activités qui nuisent à la démocratie
américaine
et qui nuisent à l'état de droit à
l'échelle mondiale.
J'espère
que la lecture de ces livres permettra
de comprendre les difficultés auxquelles
nous sommes confronté et ce qu'il
engagez-vous politiquement c'est votre
avenir c'est votre planète et c'est
votre démocratie.
Joseph Tiglitz. Merci.
Thank you.
C'est coupé.
[Musique]